[Music]
Lorraine's think here at the press line
waiting for the actors to come out of
Hall H from the big huge Marvel Studios
panel check it out you just blew all of
our minds with everything that happened
in Hall agent I want to know what were
you most excited to share because you've
been sitting on a lot of information yes
I was excited about all of it I was
excited about sharing all the face for
you're right people have been asking us
for years what's next what's happening
we said after n game after far from home
and now here we are unveiling a number
of projects over the next two years as
phase four and it feels good to finally
have it out there and have people know
why did you feel Marvel Studios Black
Widow was the right film to kick off
phase 4 because she's a character that
everybody thinks they know everything
about and she's been in so many of our
movies and you know bits of it but in no
way do you know the whole story
finally Marvel Studios Black Widow it's
happening how does it feel for you to
finally be at the helm of your own film
it's pretty surreal I mean honestly it's
I feel so raw right now because we just
got off a plane yesterday from London
and we're flying back tonight after all
this work to go back and actually
complete or keep continue on this
process we have awhile to completion
welcome to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I know what does it what does it mean to
you to be part of this huge galaxy I
don't know everybody keeps saying what
does it mean I haven't quite put my
finger on it because the last hour has
honestly been like the biggest and most
amazing but blur I mean I was in a whole
age and and I couldn't even see the back
of the room there were so many people
that were just so eager and and so
touched to see all of their heroes on
stage and that for me was equally an
amazing thing to be a part of it it's
kind of unbelievable I keep on wondering
like what kind of parallel universe I'm
in and where the normal me is supposed
to be this is my life what is it like
for you to step up into this big
literal universe well I'm feel like I'm
walking into mythology and folklore and
incredible storytelling and actually
being at backstage today there's so many
actors that I've worked with in the past
like incredible actors they really hire
very talented people the scripts are so
good the characters are so good the
directors Kate Shortland is so good the
movies are also unique in and of
themselves Black Widow is in a way a
departure I mean it feels almost like an
espionage movie it's got these all these
elements to it this is really grounded
it's very it's a little dirty it's so
salty yeah it's it's it's like bringing
some realness to the Marvel Universe
what can you tell us about your
character because things are still so
shrouded in mystery but we want to know
so Molina has been my character has been
cycled through the Red Room five times
through the widow program what can you
tell me about Mason well you know he's a
fixer you know he kind of is it and I
think yeah generally you can help people
get the things which are hard to get and
hide things and find things and and he's
got a complex relationship with Natasha
what can you tell us about Alexi well I
mean he's the red Guardian who is you
know in the comics in the Cold War
the the arms race was happening and
americo's develop new evidence of
Russian women and America developed this
thing called Captain America and so the
Russians responded in retaliation with
something called the red Guardian Alexei
just echo the last month of shooting has
been the coolest and the most surreal
experience and and to play a woman like
her and play opposite a woman
Natacha it's just so cool to see two
women I suppose like equals and and and
and I'm excited presenting that footage
today was a it was a literal dream come
true and there you have it
2020 I cannot wait
[Music]